THEY HAVE NOT THE
>> Mark: WOW.
>> Jeff: THAT'S TALENT RIGHT
THERE.
AND 12.
UP AHEAD TO
THIS IS WHERE PHOENIX
BASKETBALL.
PAUL AHEAD TO
BRIDGES MISSES I LEAD,
BOOKER ON TOP.
DEVIN
WITH THE .
>> Eddie: I WOULD LOVE TO GET C
THEY ARE REALLY HIGH ON THE
FUTURE OF THAT YOUNG MAN. JUMP .
>> Kevin: 23 ON THAT BUCKET FOR.
BOOK TURNS ON THE JETS, FINDS C.
BOOKER TO BRIDGES, TIES IT
KICKS IT OUT TO BRIDGES. NIGHT.
TURNING IT OVER
IN POINTS, REBOUNDS AND ASSISTS
DOESN'T GO ON THE GLASS. HIM.
WORKING THE CLOSE UP ON JA
>> Kevin: BOOK WITH THE PULLUP
THTH TAKE CHANCES.
PAUL, JUMPING IT UP EIGHT.
PAUL AGAINST SAY GOOD STUFF
ABOUT HIM BUT YOU NEED AGO WITHN
THE LAST FOUR NIGHTS.
UP AHEAD TO CAMGES, THE PREBOUND
AND MISS, FIN IN
TIME.
IF HE DIDN'T TAKE THAT
ON THAT VERSUS SHOOTING A TON O
GOT SIDEWAYS.
I FELT GREAT COMING INTO DEVIN
BOOKER,
DEVIN WAS
CHECK.
>> Doris: WHETHER IT'S BEENG CO
PLACE.
>> Chris: DORT-TO- BACK, YOU WAT
TO IT.
>> Ryaya
BOOK SWINGS
>> Jim: HAS DONE A
MIKAL.
CHRIS PAUL JUST PICKIVER THE
TOP WITH THE JUMP SHOT.
>>
CHOICE WORDS.
>> BRIDGES, THE WARDEN,
TYPE OF SHOTS, YOU WILL HAVE TO
>> Brian: BOOKER.
PELICANS ON THE ROAD
GOT A 2 SECOND DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN THE SHOT CLOCKYOU